hello and welcome to my debugging Python
scripts tutorial series now I know what
you're all thinking don't click away but
debugging man that's pretty lame I know
debugging is not as sexy as maybe some
other aspects of programming as if
programming is sexy but debugging is
arguably the most important programming
skill that you can even have not only is
it going to help you speed up how
quickly you can actually figure out your
errors it's also going to help you
understand what's really going on and to
avoid those errors in the future so the
bug is going to help you learn new
skills faster and progress as a
developer much quicker so in that sense
learning it to be to debug is very sexy
and you want it so let's get started now
there's a decent list of built-in
exceptions to Python there's also like
ways for module developers to make up an
exception and like give it its own name
kind of but it's actually done by
raising an exception so it's still going
to be a form of one of the exceptions
that will cover it just might give a
little bit of a snippet afterwards
basically so it can be a little bit more
helpful but as long as you understand
these these main exceptions you should
know immediately when you see that
exception what is wrong and at least be
on your way to figuring out how to fix
it so there's two exception classes so
to speak there's the base exception and
that if you ever see it it's going to
look like this it should go purple on us
yeah base exception and that is
basically an all encompassing of all
built-in exceptions so actually that's
all we're going to say on base exception
for now and the other one is just
straight-up the exception and the
difference between these is exception is
non-system exiting and also any
user-defined exception is going to fall
under the category of exception and not
base exception now don't confuse
exception with thinking that just
because you hit an exception your sister
it won't do what see
to be a system exit if you hit an
exception and you don't have any um any
pre-planned code like if you don't have
any exception handling built in your
script it will do basically a system
exit and it's going to exit so don't
think that just you'll have to worry
about it because it won't actually exit
your system or don't think that oh this
air exit my system therefore it's not an
exception that's not really the case so
anyway let's go ahead and get into it
the first exception that we're going to
cover is in a mare an a mayor is really
really simple if you see it it means
your variable is simply not defined so
let's say you have oh here's another
little tidbit everything you code
anything that might throw an error you
should have a throw it in a try and
accept loop and then accept you do an
exception and you label that as an e and
then you print out string e now what
this will do for you is if you do hit an
exception not only will it allow the
program to continue to run it'll tell
you what the exception is now you've
probably seen this on a lot of my videos
so we aren't going to just end there
I'll show you a name error so let's say
in the Tri you've got some you know some
code I don't know mob and then you have
X plus equals 1 well we've not actually
defined X so what's going to happen is
when you run it it says name X is not
defined well now hang on you said you
were going to give us a name error well
when you print the exception that's what
it's going to look like but if you want
to see the really ugly text we could
just simply do X plus plus equals 1 and
now when we run this again not only do
we get that first X we get the other X
here where you say name err X is not
defined so that's pretty logical it says
it's not defined you should be able to
be like oh it's not defined but anyway
that's a name air and immediately when
you see name air bubble is not defined
you know you've not defined your
variable at all now something that's
fairly relatable to this is something
that is actually an unbound local error
which is
kind of like this error only it's going
to say it's been referenced before an
assignment and that's what we'll be
talking about in the next video just
wanted to cover something along with
this intro to this series I hope you
guys do stick around even if you decide
you don't want to do the bugging
tutorial now something tells me you'll
be back or you'll doing a Google search
at least for your errors so highly
suggest you continue on but as always
thanks for watching thank you for your
support your subscriptions and until
next time